all right so let's talk about the next
level of fascism because i think when
people think of fascism it's sort of
it's sort of this like amorphous thing
is it is it government is it
corporations is it corporations and
government all of these forces that are
conspiring to control us at every level
and we're seeing it happen sort of right
in front of our eyes right now so you've
got you know guys like fauci who two
years later are still pulling all of the
levers of government to tell you what
you should wear on your face when you
travel but it's not just government
people right it's not just you know say
biden and fouchy and governors and
congress people it's also leaders of
corporations who are deciding what we
are allowed to say when we can say it
who can hear what you say etc etc so
there was a really interesting video
uh that was going viral yesterday of
youtube's youtube ceo susan wojciech i
believe that's the pronunciation of her
last name and she's actually calling
for more worldwide government censorship
to make her job as youtube ceo easier
take a look uh well first of all i'll
say that for uh you know we we work
around the globe and you're right
certainly there are many different laws
in many different
jurisdictions and we
um we enforce the laws of the various
jurisdictions around
speech or what's considered safe or not
safe that actually hasn't been the
controversial part what has been the
controversial part has been when there
is content that would be deemed as
harmful but yet is not illegal
so an example of that for example would
be covid i'm not aware of there being
laws by government saying around coven
in terms of not being able to debate the
efficacy
of masks or where the virus came from or
the right treatment or proposal but yet
there was a lot of pressure and concern
about us
distributing misinformation that went
against what was considered the standard
and accepted medical knowledge you know
our recommendation if governments want
to have more control over online speech
is to to pass laws to have that be very
cleanly and clearly defined such that we
can implement it
do i even have to comment on this do you
see what she did right there at the end
now we can all debate
how we can effectively communicate true
information
we all talk about science changing
you've heard of this fellow joe rogan he
has a very scary podcast where he puts
on
scientists who sometimes question the
official narrative put on this crazy guy
robert malone one of the guys who has
the most
patents related to mrna technology but
somehow that was too dangerous to get
out there and he got in some trouble
with spotify i don't have to go down
that road again but what she said there
at the end our recommendation
our recommendation you are the youtube
ceo our recommendation youtube as the
premier platform in the world to get
video out many of you most of you are
watching this on youtube right now
although i wish you'd be watching on
rumble and we're going to keep pushing
you to rubble and rumble is the future
uh but a lot of you are watching this on
youtube right now youtube is the
ubiquitous
video platform obviously okay youtube is
actually also people don't know this
it's also the second largest search
engine online meaning google itself is
the number one search engine youtube is
the number two search engine it's a
search engine in effect for video but
it's the number two search engine
overall she is calling
for governments to pass more laws so
that she can restrict speech further
because she knows she can't really do it
on her own because it gets too messy
people get upset and it's like wait a
minute you're an american company why
are you suppressing free speech then we
can get into all the debates about the
first amendment and of course that you
know youtube is supposedly a private
company but are they working with
governments all of that stuff but the
idea that the ceo of youtube would
basically say to governments worldwide i
mean look what's happening in canada
right now so she's begging now justin
trudeau who is encroaching on his
people's freedoms she's basically saying
hey trudeau liberals you guys are in
charge uh
we'd love to help you out but it would
be a little messy if we did it you know
i've got a board it's tough to do stuff
but if you just pass the law to make it
that nobody could say criticize you
justin uh yeah we could we could do what
we could yeah we'll we'll help you out i
mean think about the craziness of this
are you going to encourage
susan i'll talk directly to you we've
met once remember we had that off the
meeting
off the record meeting at youtube you
didn't want to take a selfie with me you
take a lot of selfies with other
creators when they go visit but with me
there was a pr person there and it was
very clear that you didn't really want
me there and okay that's fine um
but susan uh i don't think you should be
encouraging governments
to suppress speech because you know in
certain places in the world they treat
say gay people
badly would you want them to pass laws
so that they could not allow gay people
to speak or laws that would stifle their
speech etc etc or other minorities
religious minorities trans people
because i'm pretty sure there are some
countries that don't love trans people
would you want the government if the
governments of those places pass laws
saying you can't say anything nice about
trans people uh what are we going to do
about that and of course this you can
obviously you guys see where i'm going
with this you extend this to why wokism
just destroys everything uh because now
you've got a ceo of an
unbelievably powerful company like
google youtube like extraordinary power
unimaginable power our founders could
have never imagined something that could
have this much more power than the
government and that's what google has
they are begging governments to do their
job for them
this is a huge problem this is a huge
problem and if you don't think it's a
problem well just yesterday
defiant l's which is a huge huge twitter
account what they do on twitter they had
about 350 000 followers all they do
basically
are take screenshots of tweets from
lefties liberals whatever you want to
call them who are now wrong in their
predictions or what they have said over
the years well their account got blown
up yesterday it is now suspended deleted
it's gone it ain't gonna come back it
doesn't matter what kind of pressure is
brought to bear it ain't coming back and
why did it
get blown up well first off as i said
all that the account does all that the
account does is take screenshots to
expose hypocrisy that's all it does so
it's mirroring what other people are
saying that's it so if you were going to
suspend people you'd think you'd maybe
suspend the people with the original
information but it's not about that
they're exposing the hypocrisy they're
doing it quite well this is their last
tweet and i think perhaps guys you're
gonna see how they got away with it here
the first tweet that we have up there is
justin trudeau
from uh 2012 and he's quoting in this
tweet he's quoting stephen harper in
2005 stephen harper was the canadian
prime minister at that time and he says
when a government starts trying to
cancel dissent or avoid dissent is when
it's rapidly losing its moral authority
to govern so he's quoting stephen harper
saying that in 2005 because stephen
harper was was prime minister in 2012 so
he's trying to show trudeau trying to
show that harper is a bad dude right but
of course you all know that's exactly
what trudeau is doing now so defiance
took that to eat and then he linked it
with this one
just trudeau from a day or two ago the
ongoing blockades and occupations are
presenting serious challenges to law
enforcement's ability to effectively
enforce the law because of that the
federal government is invoking the
emergencies act to supplement provincial
and territorial capacity so all
defianels did was take one trudeau tweet
show it with another trudeau tweet
and they got blown up on twitter so when
i show you that and again they didn't
edit them there was no misinformation
it's literally just quoting
what the prime minister of canada is
saying when i show you that coupled with
the youtube ceo saying oh governments
could you could you do something around
speech so that we
don't have to do our work
you see we got a problem here